حاضر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بينيكانس
منتديات الاتفاق المبرمي بين رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المكلف بنيه من نتنياهو ورئيس
حزب العظمه اليهوديه
وقال ان نقل صلاحياتي وحده حرس الحدود
العامله في الضفه الغربيه الى سلطه وزاره
الامن الداخليه التي سيتولى لها بنغفير من
شانه ان يضر بامن اسرائيل
تقريبا
اخطاء قد تقوده للاضرار بشكل كبير بالامن
ومن شانها لقدر الله ان تكلفنا ضحايا في
الارواح تربي المستوى المهني وتجاوز
صلاحيات رئيس الاركان ومفوض عام الشرطه
والمحاكم هي وصفات اكيده للمساس بامن
الدوله والتسلسل القيادي فاحد مطالبهم نقل
قياده حرس الحدود في الضفه الغربيه الى
وزير الامن القومي لنقصير وهذا مطلب ينبع
في احسن الى احوال ميسي
دي اشياء خاصه ببنخفير
يوصلوا رئيس الحكومه المكلف في اسرائيل
زعيم حزب الكود بنيامين لتنعيم
حلفاء المحتمرين من الاحزاب اقصى اليمين
المتطرف والمتدينين المتزامتين لتشكيله لف
حكومي جديد برئاسه
مع زعيم البيت اليهودي بادعمه
الذي يطالب بحقيبه الدفاع وبصلاحيات
الموسعه في حاله استبدالها بوزاره الماليه
وكان نتنياهو وقع في وقت سابقا اتفاقا مع
كتله العظمه اليهوديه اذا عملت اثمار
يقضي باسناد حقيبتي وزاره الامن الداخلي
الى الفقير